[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله احال النائب
العام المصري اربعه من ضباط الشرطه الى
المحاكمه الجنائيه بتهمه قتل عشرات
المعتقلين من معارضي الانقلاب خلال
ترحيلهم الى احد السجون في اغسطس اب
الماضي
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في المحورين
ما هي الرؤى الحقوقيه لكيفيه التعامل
الشرطه المصريه مع الاف المعتقلين منذر
الخلاف العسكري
وما مصير التحقيقات في مختلف وقائع
الداميه الاخرى التي شهدتها مصر منذ
الانقلاب والى ما بعد فض اعتصامي رابعه
والنهضه
احاله اربعه من ضباط الشرطه المصريه
لمحاكمه جنائيه عاجله بتهمه قتل المعتقلين
اختناقا بقنابل الغاز المسيل للدموع
يمثل سابقه في مصر منذ الانقلاب العسكري
وكانت الحادثه التي وقعت في سجن ابو زعبل
في اغسطس اب الماضي قد اثارت ردود فعل
دوليه
لكن احاله المتهمين فيها الى القضاء تثير
اليوم تساؤلات عن الاستخدام المفرط للقوه
ضد معارضى الانقلاب وعن مصير التحقيقات
التي جرت في حوادث داميه مختلفه في مصر
سقط فيها وفق تقديرات رسميه الفقرتين على
الاقل من معارضي الانقلاب بينما تشير
مصادر تحالف الشرعيه الى مقتل الالاف عده
هي المره الاولى منذ انقلاب الثالث من
يوليو وتداعياته العنيفه في الشارع المصري
التي يحال فيها ضباط الشرطه للمحاكمه
الجنائيه في تهم تتعلق بقتل معتقلين من
رافض الانقلاب انكر الضباط الاربعه
المتهمون خلال التحقيقات جميع الاتهامات
التي وجهت اليهم رغم مواجهتهم بتقارير
المعمل الجنائي والطب الشرعي التي اثبتت
تعمدهم اطلاق الغاز المسيل للدموع لقتل
المعتقلين وقالوا انهم كانوا يدافعون عن
انفسهم ويحاولون من عام قليله من الهروب
اقوال تتناقض مع روايات شهود كانوا في
السياره ذاتها التي رحلت الضحايا من مركز
شرطه النصر الجديده للسيد ابو زعبل في
اغسطس الماضي ذكروا ان السياره كانت تحمل
بامر الشرطه اكثر من سعتها مما ادى الى
اختناق عدد من المعتقلين وازداد عدد
الضحايا باطلاق الغاز داخل السياره عند
فتح بابها في السجن اثار الحادث قدما
واستنكارا كبيرين في اوساط ذوي الضحايا
وغيرهم وقال حقوقيون مصريون ان اولئك
المعتقلين تعرضوا للتعذيب والحرق لطمس
الادنى على اختلافهم واتهموا السلطات
بممارسه عمليات تقل ممنهجه في ظل غياب
المحاسبه ودعوا لتحقيق دولي وتعيد
التطورات الراهنه المتعلقه بالحادث
للاذهان كل الاحداث الدمويه التي شهدتها
شوارع وميادين مصر والشكل وتفاصيل تعامل
الشرطه مع المتظاهرين المعارضين للانقلاب
الثالث من يونيو وتطرح كذلك السؤال
المتعلق ب نتائج التحقيقات العاجله
والموسعه التي امر بها النائب العام في
احداث فضل المعتصمين في ميداني رابعه
والنهضه وغيرها وتوجيهات الرئيس المؤقت
بالتحقيق في احداث دار الحرس الجمهوري ومن
هم المسؤولون واين هم مجمل هذه المستجدات
تتزامن مع الجدل الدائر حاليا حول قانون
مكافحه الارهاب و قانون تنظيم التظاهر
المطروح للراي العام و ما يثيره في هذه
الظروف بالغه التعقيد التي يعيشها
المصريون ولا يحتاجون لتنظيم تظاهرات هم
السلميه بقدر ما يبحثون عن الامن وكثير من
الحقوق المفقوده
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا هنا في
السودان الصحفى سليمان جوده ومن واشنطن
الدكتور صفي الدين حامد الاكاديمي والباحث
السياسي المصري ومن بيروت احمد اه مفرحه
الباحث في مؤسسه الكرامه لحقوق الانسان
مرحبا بضيوفنا الكرام واهلا بكم اه دكتور
صفي الدين حامد كيف تقرا اه قرار النيابه
العامه احاله هؤلاء الضباط الاربعه
المتهمين بقتل المعتقل اه او المرحلين سجن
ابو زعبل
والله انا اقرا
اه احييك واحيي جميع المشاهدين والزملاء
اه اللي معنا في البرنامج
وحقيقه قناه الجزيره طبعا ال اه هذه
الخطوه لا شك انها خطوه محموده ولكنها
يعني قليله جدا اربعه ضباط فقط اه و انا
اعتبرها اه شيء رمزي او صمام امان
اه يؤدوا منهم تنفيذ بعض الغضب الشديد
الموجود اه اولا عند كثير من المصريين
سواء في الداخل او في الخارج
والعالم كله بينظر بقلق اه لكل الانتهاكات
لحقوق الانسان وهذا يعني يعتبر ثقب بسيط
جدا
لاخراج بعض الغاز يعني ما قبل الانفجار
الذي سببه الانقلاب العسكري يعني خطوه
رمزيه هكذا موجوده
يحسب الحكومه المصريه الحاليه يعني رغم ان
هناك ملاحظات كثيره على اداء حكومه
الدكتور حازم لكن هذه الخطوه من جانب
النائب العام تحسب للحكومه لانه للاسف طول
الفتره الفتره كان هناك كثيرين يحاولون
المتاجره بهذه القضيه تحديدا على النظام
الحاكم في مصر و كانوا يتهمون الحكومه
بالتستر على الذين تسببوا فى هذه الواقعه
الان واليوم بعد قرار النائب العام اعتقد
انه ليس من حق احد ان يتهم الحكومه بانها
تسترت على متسببين في جريمه كلنا تابعناها
واسف نالها ولكن اذا كان النائب العام قد
احال انتسب بين فيها الى محاكمه جنائيه
عاجله هذا شيء اه يحسب للنائب العام هي
جريمه كما تعرف حتى الان كل ما علينا ان
نتكلم عن المتهمين احيلوا الى محاكمه
وبالتالي المتهم بريئا هؤلاء الضباط
الاربعه من الممكن طبعا ان يدانوا او
يقرؤوا لانه ال المساله في هذه القضاء
وليست سياده او اي طرف اخر لكن في الاجمال
انا اقرا معنا الواقع انه هي شهاده
للحكومه المصريه التي اتهمت طوال الفتره
الفتره انها تغطي على الموضوع وانا تتصدر
على الموضوع ولكن بهذا القرار اليوم
تغطي على الموضوع ولا تسيطر عليه وانما
كانت تحيله الى لجنه التحقيق انتهت الى
احاله اربعه متهمين فيه الى
اه احمد مفرح هل تراه قرارا اه قضائيا
اجراء قانونيا صار محضا ام له بعد سياسي
لربما
اه بسم الله الرحمان الرحيم يعني حينما اه
نرى ما قامت به النيابه العامه من
دور اه منذ سبعه اه واه اه مدى قيامها
بواجبها في اه العمل على تحقيق واه فى
وقائع قتل المتظاهرين والوقائع التي حدثت
في الشارع فاننا بلا شك نتحدث عن اجراء
نوعي لكن للاسف الشديد اه هذا الاجراء
النوعي من المفترض انه اجراء طبيعي يتم في
حالات اه لو كنا نتحدث عن دوله اه او عن
نظام يتعامل ب اه اه حقوق الانسان او
يتعامل بالقوانين اه او يت او ياخذ مثل
تلك الاجراءات اه اه اه يعني مقتل سبعه
وثلاثين شخصا اختناقا بالغاز الطبيعي منذ
بدايه الاحداث اه اه يعني حتى الان
نرى انه هناك العديد من الاجراءات التي
تمت اه اه منها تاخر القاء القبض على
الاشخاص اه هؤلاء كان من المفترض ان يتم
القاء القبض عليهم منذ بدايه الاحداث وكان
من المفترض ان يتم الاسراع في ال ال
التحريات والتحقيقات وخلافه اه اه لكن بعد
حدود هذه الحادثه اه اه بوقت طويل
وقت للاسف الشديد اه كان ممكن يؤدي ممكن
ان يؤدي الى العمل على اتلاف الادله
واتلاف الحقائق وخلافه اه ف نرى انه ليس
هذا اجراء نوعي يعني او اجراء محمود كان
من المفترض ان النيابه العامه ان تتصدر
مثل تلك الجرائم من البدايه اه وكانت
النيابه العامه
يعني اه قبل ال يعتقد هؤلاء يفترض ان هناك
مسار تحقيق وهناك اه ادله يجب ان اه تكون
ثابته جامعه حتى يصدر مثل هذا القرار هنا
نعم دكتور احمد دكتور صفي الدين حامد يعني
انت رايتها خطوه رمزيه ولكن لماذا لا يمكن
ان تحسنا كما قال اه كما قال الاستاذ سليم
ا جهودا بانها خطوه تحصى بالحكومه على
انها حينما ذهب الادله ان هناك ربما جريمه
وبالتالي لا جاءت الى ما لجات اليه
للارواح الله يعني المتهمين
نعم نعم اه يا اخي ان اقول انها رمزيه
لاسباب كثيره اه اولا لانها كما قال الاخ
العزيز من بيروت انه جاءت متاخره ودائما
ال اه بنقول هنا في امريكا دوله الكويت
يعني عدد اربع ضباط اه فقط اه واحنا
بنتكلم على الاف القتلى
ويعني اه قتلوا من بعد الانقلاب العسكري
وجاءت المتاخره الى جانب طبعا انه يعني
الموضوع يجب اه ان احنا نراه في النظره
الشموليه اه وبطريقه عموميه انه فيه شك
كثير كثير اه ما بين المصريين في الداخل
وفي الخارج بالنسبه ان التحقيقات تقوم بها
البوليس وحتى القضاء للاسف الشديد ان ال
الفتره الاخيره اه جعلت اه الكثير يشك في
بعض اه اهل الشرطه واه ويشكك كثير في اه
اهل القضاء ف اه انا معرفش ازاى نعمل
محاكمه اه تكون عادله اه ومحايده اذا كان
ال الادله ب يجمعها اه ضباط الشرطه
زملائهم احنا علينا هذا ولهذا اخرج كل اه
مبارك وخلافه وكلهم خرجوا اه ط لقاء
وابرياء لان اذا ما نقول ال اثبتت الايام
ان الشرطه المصريه لم تقوم
باعداد اه اه دلائل الاتهام للقضايا
وانتهينا الى براء كل اه مجموعه مبارك
يعني
انه من الممكن ان يدانوا
او يبرروا يعني هذا هذا ربما قد اه اه طرح
تساءل ان كانت هناك فعلا ضمانات وقد يعني
اه طرح هذه النقطه الاستاذ الدكتور احمد
صفي الدين حامد حينما قال بان من يقوم
بجمع الادله وغيرها هم رجال الشرطه
وبالتالي هم زملائهم هل من ضمانات حتى اذا
عرض هؤلاء الى اه امام المحكمه ال اه
ينتهي او يكون مصير هذه المحاكمه بتبرئه
هؤلاء الضباط كما برا من تهم بقتل
المتظاهرين في الخامسه وعشرين يناير في
مسلسل تبرئه الجميع اذا تذكر هي المشكله
انه اه يعني اه نحن احيانا او بعضنا ب ب
اه يعتبر ال ال حكم اه حكم غير عادل اذا
لم ياتي على هو اه او على ما يحب لانه اه
كل واحد من عايز المحكمه تحكم زي ما هو
عايز من زي ما القاده يرى امام القاده
يحكم بما امامه من ادله وليس بما يرى
الشارع ولا يرى الميدان وليرى المتظاهرين
في اي مكان القاضي امام وادله من خلالها
يحكم على المتهم الوقف امامه ويبرر ايدين
وهذه مساله يجب ان تكون مطلقه كليه
بالقاده انما مسلسل تبرئه الجميع او تبرئه
مبارك
وطبعا هذا هذا هذا في واقع لو ان الواقع
فعلا هذا الواقع المصري اه طبيعي وليس
استثنائي و لا تشوبه شائبه او اه اه اه
الشبهات حول القضاء وجهتها الداخليه يعني
اولا
في الميزان والمساله تاريخ يعني ك جهاز
قضائي
يعني لا يحتاج الى شهاده من احد
يعرف كيف قرار المصري يعرف انه كيف حكم في
اصعب واعقد القضايا بما يراه ضميره الوطني
وليس بما يرى اي طرف اخر وبالتالي نحن
المساله ليست في حاجه الى تشكيك مسبق في
قضيه من هذا النوع ولا في التشكيك في
قضايا السابقه وقد كنت دائما اقول بان
القضاء يجب ان يترك للقضاء وانه ال ال
الذين يتظاهرون في الشارع او الذين
يتكلمون في وسائل الاعلام لا يجب ان
ينضموا القضاء على ان يحكم حكما غير ما
تقضي به الادله المتاحه امامه ربما الراي
العام يدين شخص قبل ان يحكم عليه لكن
القضايا انه بريء من حق قضاء بغض النظر عن
عن راي الناس في هذا الموضوع والا فان
تسيس القضاء كما يقال وتدعي القضاء يحكم
على غير ما يرى من مره اخرى من ادله امام
القاب القاضي يحكم ليس بما يقول الناس في
الشارع يحكم بما امام من اجل وهذا هو
الفيصل في الموضوع كله في هذه القضيه
او في قضيه الذين اتهموا قبل في قبل
المتظاهرين لا اريد ان اذكر هنا في جدال
حول القضاء نتعامل القضاء مع المتهمين في
الاونه الاخيره كانت عليه شبهات كثيره
وحتى الاتهامات الموجهه الى الرئيس محمد
مرسي و لائحه الاتهام بدات تخابر مع الاسف
وقت متظاهرين وغير ذلك
محمد مرسي لا يعني ما
تاسيس انا اطالب بان بان لا يلجا اه
اغلبنا او بعضنا الى تسييس هذه القضايا
هذه القضايا جنائيه للقاضي ان يحكم فيها
بما يراه من اجل امامه وليس ابدا بما
يردده ان السواء في الشارع او في الشارع
او في ما يجينا ووسائل الاعلام احمد ان
نطرح اه حينما اه ترحيل هؤلاء الضباط واه
احمد مفرحه المكرمه لك اه اه يعني ت ت ت
يتهم هؤلاء الضباط ويتم الاشاره الى الى
الى رعونه واهمال اه اه الضباط واشاره الى
الجهاز بشكل عام وزاره الداخليه في تتعامل
مع هؤلاء المرحلين يعني كيف يمكن ان نقرا
ذلك
اه هل هل في ذلك ربما اتهام ل اه
المسؤولين على الداخليه انفسهم ب
بما جرى
اه بدايه يعني انا اتحدث عن ان الماتم مع
هؤلاء هي ليست المره الاولى في استخدام
الغاز المسيل للدموع القتل اه منذ الاحداث
منذ احداث 7 وما بعدها من تظاهرات كانت في
الشارع المصري ان للاسف الشديد تعامل
الشرطه مع المتظاهرين
باستخدام القنابل المسيله للدموع القتله
وليس لتفريق الجموع او خلافه شاهدنا ذلك
في الكثير من الاحداث شاهدنا ذلك في اه اه
اه الحرس الجمهوري وشاهدنا ذلك ايضا في
المنصه وشاهدنا ذلك في التظاهرات التي
كانت في مثل رمسيس وكان دورتها ما تم في
اه اه اه اه يعني الحادث الخاصه بمعتقل
ابو زعبل من قيام ضابط باستخدام قنابل
مسيله للدموع في مساحه لا تقل على اثني
عشر مترا في سياره ترحيلات فيها اكثر من
خمسه واربعين شخص وبالتالي ف اه مثل هذه
الاحداث او مثل هذا ال هذه الافعال تجعلنا
نتحدث حول مدى قيام وزاره الداخليه كلها
والعاملين فيها
والقوات الخاصه بالشرق باستخدام القانون
اه ال الذي يعطي لها حق استخدام اطلاق
الغاز المسيل للدموع او استخدام اراضيه
وخلافه وهذا يرجعنا اكثر الى قواعد
الاشتباك يعني قواعد الاشتباك في القانون
المصري هي اصلا لا ياخذ بها وان كان
القواعد الاشتباك في القانون المصري هي
اصلا مخالفه للقانون لكن للاسف الشديد لا
يؤخذ بها في الكثير من الاحداث اه ما يتم
من قبل وزاره الداخليه او بهذا الشرطه اه
في العمل على اه اه اه يعني اه اه قمع
التظاهرات السلميه التي تخرج الى الشوارع
والخلافه باستخدام قواعد الاشتباك منافيا
تماما وبالتالي فنحن نتحدث عن اه اه يعني
اه نسيج عام او عن ظاهره عامه لدى وزاره
الداخليه ليس فقط من قبل ثلاثه او اربعه
ضباط قانون باستخدام الغاز المسيل للدموع
المتظاهرين منذ اللحظات الاولى ونحن نرى
ذلك اه في الكثير من المشاهد اه حتى وصل
الامر الى استخدام مفرط للقوه في اطلاق
الرصاص الحي ليس فقط الغاز المسيل للدموع
وانما اتصل الحقيقه المتظاهرين وقتلوا في
العديد من المتظاهرات والعديد من الاحداث
اه في الشارع المصري
ولهذا فاصل قصير
مصير التحقيقات في مختلف الوقائع الداميه
التي شهدتها مصر الانقلاب والى ما بعد فض
اعتصامي رابعه والنهضه نرجوا ان تبقوا
معنا مشاهدينا الكرام
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش قرار احاله اربعه من ضباط
الشرطه المصريه للمحاكمه الجنائيه بتهمه
قتل عشرات من معارضي الانقلاب خلال
ترحيلهم الى احد السجون اه الموجوده عوده
مره اخرى الان بعد هذه القضيه في حاله
هؤلاء الاربعه لكن ماذا بخصوص اه الف حسب
احصاءات رسميه الذين قتلوا في فض اعتصامي
رابعه والنهضه
حوادث حوادث اه الحرس الجمهوري او انا
عايز بس يعني اعترض على اه اه استخدام
كلمه الانقلاب ما حدث في ثلاثين سته
تضيع الوقت
ثوره شعبيه الاركان ولا يجوز انفسهم
بانقلاب هاي مساله هذا رايي
اعتقد انه ما نصف ما حدث انقلاب عليه ان
يراجع نفسه نمره اثنين الاخ من بيروت
يتكلم عن ان الشرطه باتفاق مع المزارات
سميه هذا لم يحدث اه الشرطه تقمع
المظاهرات التي تمارس عنف او اه تعتدي على
المصالح العامه او الخاصه وداء اه كل
السؤال تؤكده اي حد رجل شرطه اعمال العنف
مع المتظاهرين كان بتقول انه هؤلاء
المتظاهرين مارس وبالتالي لابد ان فيها
احد المتظاهرين فى رابعه العدويه وهو يحمل
احد المصابين على على ظهره
يغيثه ثم اطلق عليها الرصاص وسقط
انا بتكلم على
الشرطه المصريه لا تتصدى بعنف الامن
المظاهرات التي تمارس عنف نمره اثنين
الشرطه المصريه تطلق الرصاص الحي الاعلى
الذين يهاجمون المنشات الشرطيه يعني
الوارده
في رابعه جمهوري
يطلقون عليها في 4 كان مسلحه في ربع
في اعتصام في الدنيا ثمانيه واربعين يوم
دوله اه فيها ثمانيه واربعين يوم
الاتصالات في اوروبا التي دامت اه اه اشهر
في جورجيا
اردوغان الاسبوع
المعتصمين بالغاز
طبعا
ثمانيه واربعين ساعه ثمانيه واربعين
واعتصام كان مسلحا ومع ذلك هذا المكان
الميدان 4 اه ال ال ال ال ال ال ال
التقديرات بتقول انه كان فيه حوله خمسطاشر
الف معتصم والمقاييس العالميه عندما تفض
اعتصام امس الاحد من جهه الشرطه فمن
المتوقع ان يسقط من عشره الى خمسه في
المائه من عدد الموجودين الذين سقطوا اقل
من هذه النسبه بشهاده ال ال منظمات حقوقيه
كثيره يعني موضوع 4 فيه مبالغات كثيره اظن
انها في حاجه الى مراجعه جذريه لانه
الشرطه صدرت واجهت انذار او انذارين
وثلاثه وعشر الانذارات ان على الذين اعطوا
المعتصمين في ربع ان يعودوا لابد مستقبل
البقاء وبالتالي ان يكن امام الدوله
المصريه الشرطه المصريه الا ان تتعامل مع
هذا
صفي الدين حامد يعني انتم الان اه اه في
الخارج كانوا نشطاء معارضون اه للانقلاب
معارضون خطه خارطه الطريق معارضون للحكام
الجدول حكم جديد الان في مصر ما مدى
امكانيه ان تطرح في هذه القضايا اه في
الخارج واه ما هي الجهات التي يمكن ان
تنظر فيها
نعم اه كل هذا طبعا بيناقش ما بين اه اه
اه ال المصريين في الخارج وهم يزيد عن
ثمانيه مليون وكلها يعني انا ارثي لحال اه
ال المؤسسه الصحفيه كامله والاعلاميه في
مصر ويعني نرجو من الله ان احنا نرى يوم ي
يق الاعلام و ويرجع الي شرف المهنه
ويليق به كلمه صاحبه الجلاله كما قلنا
للصحافه وخلافه
ال الحقيقه ان احنا بنتكلم على اه بعض
الاشياء تفصيل التفصيل اللي هو اه يعني
يطرا الاربع ضباط ولا
يحاكموا
يود ان ولا احنا بنتكلم عن هيئه كامله يجب
مراجعه عقيدتها وهي ال ال ال ال المؤسسه
الامنيه من ساعه ما يدخل ضابط ال لا طالب
الشرطه وهو يلقي في اعتقادي اه اشياء
خاطئه خارجه عن التاريخ وخارجه عن القرن
الواحد وعشرين لازم يعرف هذا الشخص انه
لما تخرج كليه انه يحمل رساله ساميه وانه
هو اه مرتبه بيجي من من الش من هذا الشعب
ليعطيه الامان ولا الى اه مش ان هو يتعامل
معها
الكلمه الاخيره احمد يعني اه اذا لم يتم
التحرك الداخليه في مصر ولم تظهر تحقيقات
في في ما حدث مجزره في في رابعه العدويه
والنهضه وغيرها غيرها من مذابح اه
هل يمكن احاله الامر الى اه الى المحاكم
في الخارج وهل من فرص لكي تنجح هذه
المحاولات
اه طبعا فيما يخص ال ال الجرائم التي
ارتكبت منذ ثلاثه سبعه حتى الان هي
نعتبرها نحن في الكرام وحقوق الانسان هي
جريمه ضد الانسانيه تطلب ضد المواطنين
المصريين العزل اه من قبل قوات الجيش
والشرطه التي قامت بقمع التظاهرات التي
حدثت اه اه اه وايضا اه فيما يخص حالات
الاعتقال التعسفي التي تتم ضد المواطنين
اه وايضا فيما يخص حالات التعذيب التي تم
توثيقها ضد المعتقلين داخل السجون وداخل
اماكن الاحتجاز وخلافه اه فما تم هي جريمه
ضد الانسانيه يجب على المجتمع اه اه
القانوني المصري اولا ويجب على المجتمع
الدولي ان يتدخل فيها وحينما نرى النيابه
العامه التي هي مناطقها القيام بالتحقيقات
في مثل هذه الوقائع التباطؤ وعدم العام
الاعلى اه تقديم ال الحقوق واه حفظ كرامه
المواطنين المصريين يجب على المجتمع
الدولي تبقى الاتفاقات الدوليه التي وقعت
عليها مصر التدخل اه ونحن حينما نخاطب اه
مجلس حقوق الانسان في الامم المتحده او
المفوض السامي للامم المتحده نحن نخاطب ه
للتدخل لدى اه اه مصر والنظر في اه ما
يحدث من اه اه جرائم ترتكب ضد الانسانيه
اه هو ال اه الالتزامات المصريه التي وقعت
عليها حينما اه وصل التحقيقات التي تتم مع
المتظاهرين اه اه و حينما نتحدث عن ال ال
اه المحاكمات العسكريه للمدنيين وحينما
نتحدث عن الاعتقال التوصيف المتشددون
المعتقدات بمصر الان حينما نتحدث عن
التظاهرات التي يتم قمعها في الشوارع اه
اه كل هذه الجرائم من المجتمع الدولي ان
يتدخل فيها ويجب على المجتمع الحقوق
الدولي تبقى من الاتفاقيات التي وقعت مصر
ان ينظر فيها
احمد الباحث احمد مفرح الباحث في مؤسسه
الكرامه لحقوق الانسان عذرا للمقاطعه
انتهى وقت البرنامج كنت معنا من بيروت
شكرا ايضا لضيفنا هنا في الاستوديو سليمان
جوده الكاتب الصحفي ونشكر ذكر في واشنطن
الدكتور صفي الدين حامد الاكاديمي والباحث
السياسي المصري شكرا الكرام بثلاثه هذه
الحلقه مشاه الكرام شكرا متابعتكم السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
ام